pas une mouche 2 duo prime ou choisissez
quoi aux besoins logique aux vitraux
nager pour le prime time de ces vite su
préféré parce que vous prenez le 8 et
donc la 4 ce sera le cas d'option luc
lemoine jean luc lemoine cela dit s'il
avoue ne s'en sort bien c'est un beau
cadeau
matthieu delormeau je vous le dis c'est
un grand moment qui se passe sur ses
vitres
je ne sais pas si on va se terminer sur
ça je voudrais vous demander avec nous
ce soir
un film exceptionnel juste après les
chéris demain on aura les commentaires
sur ce qu'il y avait dans cette boîte
sachez que matthieu delormeau et c'est
historique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut